A computação responsável é entendida
como o desenvolvimento da computação quântica
com consciência do seu poder
e dos seus potenciais impactos. Quando dizemos responsável,
precisamos desenvolver e usar tecnologia
baseada em princípios pré-definidos para nos ajudar a prevenir
e mitigar danos potenciais,
enquanto promovemos soluções que sejam proativamente
inclusivas e responsáveis. Na IBM,
temos sido guiados por um senso de responsabilidade
para com a sociedade há décadas. Hoje nos chamamos de catalisadores
que fazem o mundo funcionar melhor. Isso significa que
temos a responsabilidade de considerar as implicações das
tecnologias que desenvolvemos e ajudamos a colocar em uso.
À medida que desenvolvemos essa nova tecnologia,
as decisões que tomamos hoje vão influenciar o futuro,
e essas decisões
têm o potencial de causar um enorme impacto na sociedade.
Por exemplo, você pode ter que decidir se quer seguir uma aplicação
que beneficia apenas alguns stakeholders ou
uma que pode resolver um problema social.
Esperamos que você, como cliente, seja capaz de pensar
sobre o desenvolvimento responsável da computação quântica.
Pensar de forma responsável pode ajudar seu negócio a estabelecer confiança
com investidores e consumidores,
além de construir uma reputação de integridade
e admiração junto aos seus funcionários
e clientes. Por outro lado,
pode ajudá-lo a se proteger de má publicidade, multas
e penalidades. Neste vídeo,
vamos apresentar considerações importantes sobre responsabilidade
para discutir com seu time
enquanto você explora a computação quântica
e suas aplicações. Quando se trata de computação quântica,
pensar e agir de forma responsável
significa seguir um conjunto de princípios
e valores para guiar seu desenvolvimento
e implantação da tecnologia.
Por exemplo, isso significa ser transparente
tanto sobre as limitações quanto sobre as capacidades
da computação quântica hoje. Temos linguagem
em nossos contratos que exige que os clientes do IBM Quantum
usem nossos sistemas de forma responsável
e que não usem nossos sistemas
para fins nefastos ou ilegais.
Chamamos isso de cláusulas de uso responsável
e uso aceitável.
Essa linguagem já está influenciando como nossos clientes pensam
sobre o desenvolvimento quântico
para seus casos de uso. Também podemos
ajudar a influenciar a direção da computação quântica
decidindo quais aplicações perseguimos
para desenvolvimento e aceleração.
Para proteger contra usos potencialmente irresponsáveis
de nossa tecnologia, também desenvolvemos tecnologia robusta IBM Quantum
segura. Enquanto você pensa sobre como
e para que usar a computação quântica,
certifique-se de falar de forma realista sobre suas expectativas
para a computação quântica e os prazos
nos quais você espera incorporar o quântico.
Não apresente a computação quântica
como algo misterioso. Tente explicá-la de forma realista
como hardware de computação
que segue as regras da física quântica.
Certifique-se de que seu caso de uso para computação quântica
seja proativamente inclusivo
e esteja considerando todos os stakeholders potenciais
para determinar a extensão
de quaisquer impactos sociais negativos.
Certifique-se de ter definido princípios claros
e valores para a exploração do seu caso de uso
e desenvolvimento. Obrigado
por assistir. Esperamos que,
ao levar a computação quântica útil ao mundo,
você também pense em como pode fazer isso de forma responsável.
The the